and then i got covered last time on
abby's sibo saga
[Music]
you're in peeling this never-ending
onion there's just so much to unpack and
none of it is black and white
oh my god these ones all okay i mean
there are so
many
options recommended for sibo like it's
but i'm not gonna make myself crazy
about this sibo is still notoriously
very hard to get rid of
i'm so frustrated
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
as usual a big reminder that this is my
unique healthcare journey so always
speak to a healthcare provider about
your unique needs okay so i want to
update you on where i'm at right now
in this kind of sibo journey but before
we get into it a big thank you to brooke
lennon for sponsoring today's video so i
have to be honest my sleep has not been
great these days despite me doing like
all the things if i feel really bloated
or in pain before bed it can be really
hard to get comfortable and since we
spent like a third of our life in bed i
really wanted to get the comfiest sheets
i could afford but most high quality
luxury sheets are like 400 or more and i
got kids to put through college so i
recently discovered brooklyn and sheets
and after one night i am totally
hooked so comfy i did not want to get
out of bed they are all about delivering
quality and comfort at an affordable
price by cutting out the middleman so i
got their classic hardcore bundle sheets
which i love because they stay super
cool all night long which is key
because i run super hot it's also ideal
to get their hardcore bundle because you
save 25 instead of buying each item
individually and you get the core sheet
set extra pillowcases and duvet cover
they also have 20 different colors and
patterns that you can mix and match and
cost a fraction of other luxury sheets
so you're really looking at 200 to 250
dollars a set depending on the size not
to mention their reputation definitely
speaks for itself i spend a lot of time
reading reviews before i make purchases
and brooklyn has over 90 000 5 star
reviews that's actually insane so if you
want to try out brooklyn and yourself
they're currently offering my viewers 20
off any purchase over 100 using my code
abby sharp so check out the link below
to see basically my current protocol as
of today
after i finished my antibiotic treatment
is that i'm just taking my prokinetic
which is called resotran which is really
to help prevent relapse by supporting
motility and then for supplements i'm
taking my ginger
peppermint iberogast enzymes sun fiber
ox bile colostrum magnesium and my
probiotics
i'm taking both an s bulardi probiotic
and orthospore probiotic and other
things i'm doing is i'm continuing to
try to space out my meals which has
actually become like totally intuitive
to me it feels good it's what i do
naturally i like it things i'm more
mindful about is i'm avoiding artificial
sweeteners like splenda
i'm not really having a ton of raw
vegetables or any meal salads and i'm
eating usually like two kiwi fruit a day
and i'm trying to stick to mainly cooked
lower fodmap veggies for my meals but
tomorrow is
sibo testing day again i hate this i
don't want to do things i want to not do
things
just like you taught me uh so i'm living
off of my white carbs and my eggs and my
chicken again and i'm definitely looking
forward to my first
latte post-test
[Music]
last one
hope that worked
i got my coffee in one hand and i got my
sun fiber in the other
i'm going for the coffee first
hallelujah i got through it okay so i'm
expecting to get my test results pretty
much any day now but i want to share
with you a little update on how i'm
feeling about a month out of treatment
so basically i feel much better but not
perfect this is gonna be tmi um but then
again like what isn't on my channel
but if we were to pull up the bristol
stool chart i would be getting like
textbook
three or four type
stools which is really like gold
standard that's what we want to go for
so
we like that what has not resolved is my
bloating and distension and just
generally my tolerance to other kind of
high fodmap foods or generally quote
healthy foods and i know that because of
how different i felt when i was
basically
doing the sibo diet for two days which
is very low fiber like all white carbs
and a little protein so my stomach
looked and felt visibly smaller
during the two days that i was on this
sibo prep diet and then i kind of went
back to looking and feeling like i was
six months pregnant
the minute i ate a vegetable that tells
me something's still not quite right so
yeah even though symptom management
might be better on like a fiber-free
diet
uh
definitely not great for long-term
health myself or the health of my
microbiome so yeah something's probably
still up and if it's not sibo it's maybe
something in the large intestine um and
thankfully we got data on the way so in
addition to the sibo breath test i also
just completed what we call a
gi 360 test which by the way i have
absolutely no affiliation with but
basically there are a variety of stool
based tests like this this one uses pcr
technology and growth based culture
technology
to look for a variety of
pathogens
different bacteria parasites
viruses and basically maps your
microbiome for a wide range of bacteria
but it's important to note that this is
not a great test we don't have validated
evidence-based references for what's
necessarily
normal and what's not so we're really
depending on the results pool for this
information which makes it a flawed test
and not ideal or appropriate for the
basis of recommendations on its own if a
practitioner tries to tell you that it
is amazing and it is the sole basis for
recommendations
run but it's what we have right now um
maybe one day the technology will
improve and we'll catch up and the
research will catch up but it is
relatively low risk i mean as long as
it's not cost prohibitive for you um and
it is pretty sensitive so if you have a
skilled practitioner to walk you through
results and pair the results from the
test to your actual symptoms then it can
help to inform treatment so we take it
as like a piece of evidence and until
the science improves you know i really
try to take each piece of evidence with
a grain of salt okay so i got the
results of both my sibo test and my gi
360 test they just came in here and it
looks like we've got some good news and
some not so good news
the good news on the sibo test is that
this antibiotic protocol
wiped
out of the methane bacteria which is
definitely the more stubborn bacteria to
treat and really was the goal of this
protocol the not so great news is that
as we've seen the methane bacteria
basically become eradicated uh in the
test results we see the hydrogen
bacteria emerge which according to my
colleague anya rosen when i asked her
about this she said this is really not
uncommon to see basically the methane
bacteria consume the hydrogen so if
there's methane bacteria present it will
always look like the hydrogen levels are
low because it's using that hydrogen as
fuel but once the methane bacteria are
gone it's a lot easier to see the true
hydrogen bacteria count annoying yes but
the good news is that hydrogen-based
bacteria are a lot easier to treat than
methane so i'm gonna do easy round of
herbal antimicrobials to give myself a
rest from all of the antibiotics i've
been doing and just hope for the best as
for the gi 360 test this comes with a
really comprehensive and overwhelming
results package that basically maps out
the entire large intestine so it's
definitely not something that you want
to try to unpack yourself because you
can go down a dangerous black hole on
google filled with misinformation so
definitely definitely definitely work
with a trained specialist to unpack your
results but in short my results were not
surprising at all um and if anything
kind of better than i expected i guess
the good news is i have no pathogenic
parasites or anything like that thank
goodness the not so great news is that i
have pretty significant dysbiosis which
is an imbalance of good and bad bacteria
which again is to be expected after
doing such heavy-duty antibiotics don't
forget that it's theorized that
antibiotics basically put me in this
position in the first place and i want
to flag that antibiotics are life-saving
and absolutely were necessary in my
situation i had mastitis five times it
was quite horrible anyone that's had
mastitis can definitely relate to that
but we don't want to overuse them
because this does have potential
implications other things we learned was
that my gut ph was high my elastase was
low which typically indicates poor
digestive outputs like poppy sorry poppy
oh my goodness
they're having fun so other things we
learned was that my gut peach was high
my last taste was low which typically
indicates poor digestive outputs like
you know stomach acid and enzymes and my
secretory iga uh was quite low very low
actually which typically indicates
stress surprise surprise so i'm just
like
we're living in a global pandemic so
this is not discouraging to me
so this is not discouraging
craziness out there this is not
discouraging to me um if anything this
is exactly what i would expect after the
heavy duty antibiotics that i've been
through and i actually think that fixing
this piece will be way easier
than killing off the methanogenic
bacteria that we just eradicated so i'm
actually feeling quite optimistic about
all this okay so now let's talk about my
new protocol
this thing is effing never ending but to
deal with the stubborn lingering sibo
i'm going to try four weeks of my
biofilm disruptor bismuth style complex
plus two powerful herbal antimicrobials
i'm going to do oregano and berberine
and for the rest of the dysbiosis
situation the goal now is to really like
repopulate the gut with good bacteria so
i'm going to continue with the
orthospore probiotics which not only
will help with the bacteria but it also
contains immunoglobulins which will help
to replenish the immune system to
support the suppressed secretory iga
levels now to deal with the high ph this
is really a sign that i might need some
stomach acid support so i'm going to get
back on the butane hcl um as for the low
elastase that's often a sign of
suppressed enzymatic function so i'm
going to continue with the digestive
enzymes that i was taking and also again
a reminder that most folks do not need
digestive enzymes um and a test like
this is so helpful to determine if you
actually do but sibo notoriously
diminishes normal enzymatic function so
this is like a temporary tool that i
might need to lean on as i work towards
replenishing and ultimately healing my
gut now the most exciting piece for me
is that i gotta get those hydrogen
bacteria you know revving and rolling
and hopping and howling and just happy
i think i'm getting excited are you
getting excited let me see you do that
yeah you're getting excited and to do
that means i gotta eat all the fodmaps
and i might get a little uncomfortable
but i'm up for the challenge so
here's a little preview of some of the
yummy things i ate
[Music]
and then i got covered i can't really
explain how
unbelievably unlucky and
may i say unfair it is that my family
has coveted right now we have gone
above
and beyond to
prevent this and to keep my kids safe i
have sacrificed
all of my physical and mental health to
do this it has really impacted every
facet of my life for the past two years
and yet it still got me without going
into detail um
all i'm gonna say is that
the cdc's recommendation of like five to
ten days
isolation period uh five days for fully
vaccinated adults definitely
not adequate in a lot of cases such as
mine like we were infected over three
and a half weeks after a person became
exposed and that was with three negative
pcr tests it's hard to explain without
going into detail but it definitely
feels like a huge kick in the crotch at
this point
uh my kids are doing okay
oh has had no appetite though and kind
of on and off fevers all week he's
definitely not himself he's in much
better shape i
have been
so nauseous i feel like i'm pregnant
definitely took pregnancy tests um but
i'm having a really hard time
maintaining momentum with my sibo
protocol this threw a real wrench in the
mix but basically i have only felt like
eating like super binding foods so rice
bread rice cakes rice crackers um pasta
bananas fruit yeah so all that is kind
of slowing down my motility and my bowel
function which is obviously not what we
want for sibo recovery but i really
cannot bring myself to eat anything else
but i'm taking this day by day um
obviously i'm going to continue with the
protocol do the best job that i can just
pray that my appetite comes back and i'm
able to tolerate normal amounts of food
normal variety in food and of course be
sure to maintain my supplement regimen
especially the fiber the fiber is going
to be key because i'm probably not
getting a whole lot of fiber from my
diet right now seeing as i really only
can tolerate like tomato soup and bread
so update kobe kicked my ass
wasn't expecting that but at the same
time that i got covered i got my natural
period for the second time in about 20
years um and that's because i was on the
pill like basically my whole adulthood
and then when i came off i went straight
into ivf and from ivf i was pregnant
then breastfeeding then ivf then
pregnant then breastfeeding so it took a
while for me to get a natural period
back um and just for my cycle to
regulate itself after having so many
years of synthetic hormones in my body
so i think the covid plus the sibo
medication that i was taking plus the
period all of those things combined made
the perfect storm for me to feel like
[ __ ] i felt super nauseous for like
three weeks
and had pretty bad diarrhea as well
yeah i know tmi so two days ago i was on
day 27 of my four-week sibo protocol and
i had a call with my rd colleague and
she said abort mission and just like
take it easy rest recover and then
revisit treatment and on the same day my
nd said well you know what if you're not
feeling horrible um why don't you wait
and see what happens when your period
ends because she felt it was likely a
lot more to do with the period than the
sibo medication or the covid and she
said why don't you wait it out and see
what happens and how you feel after your
period ends and basically the next day
my period ended and lo and behold the
clouds opened up the angels started to
sing and i stopped feeling like so i am
kind of glad that i just kind of stuck
it out a little longer just to see
because there were a lot of moving parts
so it was very hard to see you know what
was and wasn't a confounding factor in
my symptoms but i am actually finding
that my bloating and distension seems to
be getting a lot better um and also of
course my appetite is finally coming
back after it being just so low for
those two or three weeks of coven and
since i am feeling better we decided i
would tack on an extra two weeks of my
herbal treatment and then retest so wish
me luck lovelies and please stick around
to see how it all shakes out and until
then don't forget to check out the link
in the description to get 20 off of your
brook linen purchase over 100 using my
code and if you like this video be sure
to give it a thumbs up leave me a
comment below if you have any more
questions about sibo digestive health
any other ibs related symptoms etc don't
forget to subscribe to this channel and
i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]